je suis
d'accord
je passais
[Musique]
j'assume
longuet
on presque précédent
nous avons marre tu es de ma mémoire qui
m'a bringue
mais mieux
[Musique]
je suis dans mon élément
m
amir khadir
c'est ni comme des dingues comme au
milieu
[Musique]
sachez que ce que
et un jour
tu ne reviens pas me chercher peut être
tout l'enjeu des glandes victime
d'agrémenter
[Musique]
ils vont agiter manque ici
me revient un jour passer à la télé
comme le prête pour qu'on trouve à
prague
[Musique]
séducteur
pour garder ce qui me rend
tout cet arthur de silicone match
ah ah
[Musique]
je
te manquer
jusqu'à demain
mais je passais institut d'histoire
la suite on le
attaché ce sont des contenus de bouillon
de flashbacks infinie ici les jeunes aux
flammes
[Musique]
justement
m
non
[Musique]